ciao ragazzi ben tornati nella mia
cucina o se il mio salotto come potete
vedere da dietro di me
come potete vedere da ciò che c'è dietro
enrico luigi no è già notte ma ok perché
perché mia mamma è venuta diciamo
rimasto poi a chiacchierare stamattina
ci siamo presa comoda col dg visto che è
arrivato ieri che era tardi e adesso
abbiamo deciso di metterci finalmente a
lavoro a registrare quello che è
successo mi sto eccesso una presa molto
molto comoda quindi partiamo con questa
puntata di cucina buttata un saluto le
telecamere storia il natale di saldare
il brivido proprio noto che questi sono
già aperti devi dichiarare qualcosa di
elmo ma voi dichiarare pure tu qualcosa
oggi vogliamo fare l'esperimento ossia a
trasformare un pandoro in un pupazzo di
neve facendo però un ripieno per non
renderlo troppo noioso quindi pensavamo
a un ripieno al tiramisù
detto ciò abbiamo comprato anche
qualcosina per fare delle decorazioni
ma la maggior parte ci siamo mangiati
non ci abbiamo pensato che servivano per
decorare guglielmo si vuole collaborare
con noi potremmo considerare la loro
proprio studio lo facciamo ripieno
procedente e poi fare il ripieno avevamo
bisogno di grave la classica crema al
mascarpone molte persone fanno la camera
e la scarpone senza pastorizzare le uova
non è uno buono da me non ho mai
successo niente
non buono io ho la fortuna di avere un
macchinario con me pastorizza altrimenti
ma credo pastorizzare un formatore
dimostrare come si pastorizzato tutti
quando l'abbiamo già fatto vedere nel
video fratello l'abbiamo già fatto
vedere nei video tiramisù quindi sole
vedere così vasta zona europa
cliccate sul video del tiramisù
altrimenti continuate a guardarlo 60
sapete luigi che cosa hai in mano
per prima cosa iniziamo prendendo due
perché facciamo le cose in grande 2
pandori e gli apriamo bassa guglielmo
mangia sta io tu ti stai sfondando
voglio tra non molti del faggio l'idea
mia è quella di patrice casey non mi
serviva quel pezzo almeno non adesso non
è il massimo cercando ora di capire in
che modo
non so se capisci che ora può sembrare
brutto però tutto questo qui verrà
ovviamente de corato taglio pure qui
abbiamo sbagliato riposizioniamo si
berrà deve venire per forza questo punto
tagliamo qui venite tarantino magica
prepariamo la bagna che volevo farle con
il caffè ma non li dico per fare la
bagna perché dovremmo farla col caffè se
vogliamo farlo tiramisù ma vi farà
ancora altro caffè in questa cucina
esploso qualcuno parla
ma io devo farne sette chili di hai
appena detto che non faremo la bagna
perché non mi va di fare tutto questo
caffè ma a casa potete benissimo fare un
litro di incastrare spennellarli nelle
fette come non mi va proprio
noi de fare crema di mascarpone nome
utilità che se i pooh fa solamente che
due colli le altre quattro sono interi
questo eravamo monterey mai questo pezzo
è mai una volta che lo mondi so già che
paralisi e ultimo turno ho visto
dell'album e in quella coccia io quante
cose vedo che ti scoccia lo ricordate
che uscire da questa cucina te lo posso
dire vattene via vattene via
qui spacchiamo lì per sei minuti dire le
perle sappiamo libro numero 6 muri
distacco fino a 1 spagna ammetto che ho
fatto devo pastorizzare le uova
pastorizzate e devo sbattere con lo
zucchero non da sole da sole stavano che
le sbatte a fare in faccia mesi male da
sola erano in sei
preghiamo che funzioni in quale è molto
innovativo come
pulisci avvicinato che c'è stata la
bocca di baschi la polvere si sono le
mogli che in questo modo è più facile
capito che non
il problema è andrea ha registrato lo
scorso non ne sia accorto come è
avvenuta statalizzazione fatto andare ad
una temperatura che non le cuoceva ma
che era abbastanza calda da abbattere
eventuali batteri come quando è tenuta
irene cucina buttata che lei lo fa
prendendo lo zucchero mettendo nel
pentolino diventa uno sciroppo e a quel
punto a filo lo metti nell'uomo che
viene sbattuto e quindi essendo caldo e
vice battuto sbattuto e simpatia gretta
sbattuto ok nella generosa vediamo fra
sei minuti stacco di coscia
a questo punto aggiungiamo la crepa un
chilo di mascarpone
si chiama la ricotta c'è chi lo fa con
la panna mascarpone non so voi katyn
siate aiutato il mascarpone questi dolci
fatti un po a metà per me è meglio non
si rimangi f prima e se anche più
coerente con te stesso team mascarpone o
mascalzone aggiungiamo a cucchiaio il
mascarpone
ieri tutti i nomi ma non dire addio o
meno che non sei team mascalzone
caspita vivendo un cucchiaino uomo sono
finiti quindi avrai questo coppino
i ragazzi vorrei fare una domanda domani
noi saremo in viaggio per andare a
catania
ora voi vedete questa cosa vedo io ok mi
fate sapere qua sotto sera a casa aveva
però serviva che facciamo una piastra
enrico mense migliorato sempre più
lunghi dati chic mai non fatemelo sapere
passo facciamo la piastra enrico se ci
sono altri commenti non puoi non puoi
non voi ne parlano esimenti deve tornare
contento dobbiamo vivere se questo così
non l'ho letto ma poi lo pulisco bene ti
fa schifo non lo dovevo riutilizzare
vivendo in un mero pulisci molto bene ma
è molto motore che pende come via
guglielmo di pulire veramente bene
percolati faccio vedere come lo deter
giamo prima mettiamo questo qui in frigo
guglielmo aspetta un attimo
no no apri non so cosa ci possa essere a
5 novembre 19 questa quindi figurati
pensile carico come non lo cavare la era
il 3 pare di meglio su ball peggio dei
luoghi
tu sei ato adesso sto pure neppure con
lo spazzolone maestro finale questo
perché da enrico più sapone perché già
pato sia in altro po non sento la
plastica scorticarsi ma enrico mi sento
sento le mie mani che esistono
scalpitando dei tributi dei tributi ma è
dentro i buchi
[Risate]
ripresa dentro l'occhio sa mai esposti
di nuovo di no a questo punto io vorrei
andarci giù pesante
intanto facciamo un mezzo chilo di panna
fresca è scoraggiato e rigore stagione
decidendo se ti presenti zolfo è stato
evocato satana iniziamo ad assemblare
tutto quanto ha bisogno era un botto
era un botto il tuo stomaco
adesso sto rimettendo gli strati che ho
fatto prima al loro posto con la
differenza cristo intervallando con la
crema al mascarpone
no ho sbagliato volevo metterci anche
del kakà va bè iniziato questo strato
quanto ce ne misto con questo termine
tutto sbagliato volevo è un po storto
guglielmo ma che è fatto accaduto
scusate volevo salvare questa situazione
mamma che disastro
con tale disagio ma proprio cioè
stremato dove la forma di un po la vedo
un po sotto ecco questo chiudiamo qui
che non pensava essere avanzata così
tanto mi dese se succede qualcosa se
faccio questo mare che carino avevo
letto da qualche parte che se un dolce
pende a mettere uno stoppino uno
stampino quindi io mi metto tutto quanto
una base
ecco il danno è no perché così ora
scenderà tutta quanta ottenere una serie
pezzo vabbè adesso che può sembrare
cugino it del natale andremo a salvare
tutto quanto con la panna montata che
farà l'effetto neve sopra i video di è
un mega la panna di basta mi cine un
attimo il piatto non è un pupazzo di
neve questo punto lo lascio dire che non
approvazione per me sembrava molto
importante questo procedimento per
renderlo un pupazzo di neve
importante il giusto magna da un'altra
cosa
non sto mangiando niente della mia
faccia
prendiamo due ore o e facciamo gli occhi
gli facciamo un naso verrà il cerino e
prendendo una liquirizia e facciamo la
bocca i bottoni da e delizioso non sei
serio e facciamo un po di terriccio
cosa dovrei fare con questi altri due
biscotti mette un pochino cioccolato
fondente la base così capita
vai a vedere il pupazzo lu lu ti stiamo
portanto il pupazzo è chino bt nun io
enrico lo è io sia
vabbè fatto se dovevo magnate farcito
con della crema quell'impegno non c'è
stato anche se la resa del pupazzo e poi
uniti vi guarderà mentre lo valutate
come l'ho fatto un'altra idea di come
sarebbe uscito ma i dolci ma anche
essere dolci non è bello ua un
dolcissimo sempre l'ultimo il primo
grado di quello sguardo che cosa ci puoi
dire a questa dolcezza assaggio e dimmi
che fa schifo mi vidi che fa schifo non
avremo tutto sommato no si può mangiare
come si fa a mangiare così ci vuoi fare
mancano i litri di un high di esclusione
di chi ricopre una deliziosa 10 1 è
bellissimo
da quando è più parcelle piedi ma il mio
mito sono piene di gente
un successo è innanzitutto la porzione
troppo grande
di tutto domani piastra poi adesso si
vede lo scrive però non lo fa l'assaggio
saggio e buono con un po di caffè
sarebbe stato meglio raga meglio fatelo
a casa col caffè molto buono però ma io
me ne son enti che qui s'è preso disse
sempre servisse però bisogna bisogna
dire un messaggio importante l'estetica
non rappresenta ciò che abbiamo dentro
la copertina non rappresenta la bellezza
del libro bravo tutto quello che ora
l'abito non fa il monaco e piccole di
tre magro ma dov'è il giorno in viaggio
gireremo quello che che ci succederà per
annunciano delle code infinite
impazziremo ma siamo ormai a meno care
quindi teniamoceli stretti perché poi
passerà un altro anno è già un pochino
sono triste
ciao